yeah what I got sold yeah Rio yeah is
that racism no way when I do that no
that guy because I do it I do it though
when I see my friends what kind of
friends like if I see you like if I see
like Ian Edwards with like oh oh you
rock yeah that's really yummy and they
play along you obviously haven't seen
the movie dear white people I know but
I'm not white I know can I give you guys
an example I know there are sponsors
that I really love beachbody.com I do I
do this isn't an ad here we're not
picking pay this episode but it's it's
okay so one of the main guys he's the
main guy on p90x and he does this
hardcore one with just like military
people right and it's a great workout
but I always put it on mute and I just
follow it because every time he sees a
black guy he kind of does what you do
which I will sup my brother and it makes
me feel so awkward
yeah Tony Horton is your yty okay and he
looks at a guy who's like a
light-skinned black guy and he he always
draws parallels he's like oh this is um
what's a basketball players name from
the warrior golden Steph Curry yeah this
is Steph Curry's brother right here and
then he'll look at a light-skinned black
woman but Michael Jackson will sup the
workouts I do many ways but I put him on
mute because I can't it makes me feel
what I hear when people are like
oblivious to race in that way like when
I'm at the spa and I run into Paulie
it's so dreadful yeah because your
Chinese because you know the croaks do
Koreans there do you don't [ __ ] with em
you know they have wads of money there
were glasses at night at 3:00 in the
morning in doors you know I mean they're
they're [ __ ] not [ __ ] around yeah and
so when he does that I have to go to
chill because I just love Chinese people
don't say I'm not
but like he does that and there's
nothing I can do about it because he'll
just stop you if I really get mad I'm
afraid you know there are consequences
mmm you know so I don't say anything
without Howard Lee of me know a little
bit yeah would it mean I think that you
should have more like fiber in your
being more moral fiber to stand up for
Asians as a whole that's one [ __ ]
person but if you say no to poly so
you're absolutely wrong about that I'll
tell you why if they ever talk about
Missy and what she did with the Thai
people know but the rest restaurant I
can't even I can't believe I'm telling
the story please
but I'll just say it okay here I'll just
walk around that Coco so Tyra Mitzi said
something to me that I was hurt my
feelings
mm-hmm and I went to my a sponsor at the
time and I was 23 24 and I was going to
meetings and in San Diego a lot and I
walked her to him and I go yes she
really said this and really hurt my
feelings and he goes what do we have to
do is you have to write the steps about
it right you have to write down why why
you're resentful do a column and then
also approach her and tell you how you
feel about it and how that you have a
resentment and I go I'm not doing that
that's a little excessive he's like no
but you have to because I don't know I
don't because that works anywhere else
in the world except for her she does she
doesn't play by she she she's one of
those like when I went to the airport
once with dice and he smoked inside the
airport he literally lit up a cigarette
inside the airport and I you're not
supposed to do that either what are you
gonna do Ching you know like you don't
they just they do what they want you
know what you're in that sense you're
right I guess if it was a different
person if it wasn't Paulie you'd be like
hey dude you can't say that to me
but he
is incorrigible he is he cannot be
changed he can't be changed he is we is
and I love him and he started my career
yeah
so call me Chinese everything right but
what I'm saying though is is that if I
walk up to Tony rock or whatever whoever
it is right angle whatsapp you know I do
that I just listen all right to me it's
not as bad as a white person doing it
George key try it I'll say so what's up
Michael Jackson say that yo what's up
Michael Jackson it's weird when you try
try but here's why I believe because
we're on the same list as African
Americans on the KKK list now you guys
yeah pretty much
all right so in their view we're all one
thing although we're like ninth on the
list yeah
[Music]